well wouldn't you know comedian Samantha
bee is suffering pretty much no
consequences at all for her repugnant
attack on Ivanka Trump and the liberal
media double-standard apparently also
applies to MSNBC's joy read over the
last few weeks hateful and nasty blog
posts by read from as far back as 20
2005 they've all surfaced so well she's
repeatedly apologized for the posts her
network says she has evolved and her
show remains on the air joining me now
one of Reid's
targets New York Times bestselling
author and Coulter and great to see you
I'm sure none of this surprises you I
mean this is what you and I have come
become accustomed to liberals can say
anything they want about women
minorities Jews and get away with it but
you found some interesting nuggets from
her past
yes it actually went up on Daily Caller
today one was she was wishing for you
and me to be left in the public square
in a rock which i think is is
interesting because I agree I wouldn't
want to go to a majority Muslim country
I don't know why liberals want to turn
this country into those countries but
that's she considered that really you
know the worst thing you could do to us
and then in a separate post I guess she
liked or retweeted someone suggesting
that I don't know if it was just me or
both of us kill ourselves and then of
course there was the always popular
calling me a man for having a beautiful
swan-like neck liberal women as long as
we're being frank here aren't used to
that because they have rolls of fat on
their now really taken aback by my
beautiful swan-like neck but the point
of all this is I mean these nasty nasty
things that get posted by liberals it
shows they just wanted to get rid of
Roseanne I've been told my entire life
oh no you know newspapers TV stations
they're just trying to make money it's
whatever the public wants no it isn't it
has never been that liberals say much
much worse things but they're part of
the political agenda the reason they
wanted to fire Roseanne was I mean she
used to be kind of a left-wing loon
she became a trump supporting still kind
of alone but she had a wildly popular
program and apparently it was popular
with Trump supporters whom they enjoy
calling racist did you see that they're
trying to maybe reboot the show without
her with just her daughter who's
obviously the more liberal character
which and John Goodman apparently said
I'd be I'd be up for that I mean but
this is the kind of ideas that happen
there's half of the country who voted
voted for Trump by roughly all these
people are looking for something that
just doesn't offend them on a
minute-by-minute basis and this show
kind of had some funny moments where
someone who liked Trump wasn't ridiculed
every five seconds so that's all it was
it wasn't even all that political of a
show but I bet you know the producers
people behind this show they were tired
of having the answer for it at various
social events in LA or Malibu they don't
want to answer this is this is a this is
a nice kind of ugly way of saying oh
this is off the air we can go back to
doing doing business as normal and right
right I mean I never saw the old short
show or the new show but when she was
getting ratings like we haven't even
heard of or 20 years to be to be dumping
that show because of crazy tweets she
was sending she has always seemed crazy
to him this is nothing new I mean you
know I don't want to be sent to the
concentration camp yes I condemn her
tweet but but she's always sent crazy
tweets that are deserving of the
condemnation it has nothing to do with
that and if they really cared about
offensive tweets and and so on will
obviously Samantha be enjoy read
wouldn't be on air but yeah yeah we've
got to keep them and I want to talk
about where this party is going I talked
earlier to Dinesh about this and how
everything has become radicalized they
claim that trumps the radical where he's
kind of really pretty mainstream and
wants to work with Democrats on trade
and other issues and yet we see the
Democrats now lurching toward perhaps an
Elizabeth Warren a Kamala Harris maybe
Cory Booker in 2020 and then you have
the old establishment figures like John
Boehner out there a couple of days ago
he came out and he's still sniffing and
harrumphing clearly about Donald Trump
let's watch I want to talk to you about
what's
happened with the Republican Party there
is no Republican Party there's a Trump
party the Republican Party is kind of
taking a nap somewhere what do you think
about all whole Boehner is comment I
hope it's not a nap I hope it's dead
I want the Republican Party to be the
Trump party we might start winning again
but I thought John Boehner was off
promoting marijuana or something yeah he
joined some they don't wanna board and
you know he said he was always against
marijuana until he just became an
advisory board member of you know in
other words kind of an informal lobbyist
for legalizing pot across you know why I
want the Republican Party dad just move
it aside and I mean it should go the way
of the Whigs this is this is I think a
great turning point as it was with when
Lincoln took over that party has served
its purpose Alec did was lose election
serve corporate interest now Trump has
to know when he actually ran on yeah
well yes it is a long road to hoe there
and Coulter thanks so much